all right welcome back to the show let's
go to the phone lines and hear
what's on people's minds today we are
taking calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's start today
with a caleb from atlanta caleb from
atlanta
you are you're on the air what's going
on
hi david um i was wondering
what your thoughts are on the future of
i guess political discourse in this
country it seems like
donald trump has really just
made everyone like very unable to
just talk about anything nowadays and
i was wondering if there's any recovery
from this or like
the future of i guess conservatives more
generally
yeah it's really going to depend it's
going to depend on two things
the republican party is going to have to
decide whether
the coarsening and debasement of the
discourse that happened under donald
trump whether they want to keep things
that way or not
now if you go back to the george w bush
era
there was a hell of a lot of debasing
and and coarsening of the discourse then
but it was nothing compared to what we
saw under donald trump you know
uh mocking disabilities and uh i mean
listen i don't have to give you the full
list
you know it of course um i think that
the left also has a role to play
in the sense that the left could make a
stronger
stand about we are just not going to
accept
some of this very base
way of talking about politics as valid
and we're just not going to engage
in it but i have a i worry that that
could have the backfire effect that the
right will say the left doesn't want to
hear any ideas that are different than
their own
but i think that unfortunately a lot of
this depends on whether the republican
party says
we we have to step up the the level of
debate a little
or whether they you know they if they
perceive that they benefit
from the way donald trump has debased
the discourse then they may continue
they may decide it's good for them
yeah definitely um thank you thanks for
your time
all right caleb i'm gonna let you go
sounds like you've got a lot going on
there but i do
very much appreciate you uh calling in
always great to hear from folks all over
let's go to dwayne from buffalo new york
dwayne from buffalo you're on the air
duane from buffalo please unmute
yourself you were
on the air and you could be speaking to
me right now if only you unmuted
yourself
can you hear me david yes i can hey
how's it going good good
good yeah i just wanted to call in and
say you have a
intellectually stimulating show
listen to you and kyle kalinski and uh
yeah just keep up the good work you
really um
you're doing a good job and making
people think very hard about
uh what's going on in society keep it up
i appreciate that so okay so you
you watch the david pakman show you
listen to kyle what else is in your
media diet so to speak
uh new york times local news
uh unfortunately cnn and msnbc
sometimes just for fun i'll take a quick
peek at newsmax
okay and uh one american news but i'm
not
really uh obviously i don't listen to
that seriously
and from the standpoint of independent
left-wing
media is there anything else in addition
to to kyle
uh not really um the young turks of
course
okay but i don't really listen to them
as much as i listen to you guys
but i still do my independent research
you know and collaborate things to make
sure
that i'm getting a full like world view
of everything
well it sounds like you're making every
effort to have a well well-rounded uh
diet
is it what what's the scene in buffalo
in terms of
masks and virus guidelines right now
well our colby cases have been going up
pretty sharply here especially where i
am
but hopefully the political leaders to
get everything under control you know
especially with the vaccine right around
the corner
i'm really looking forward to that um
but you know
you still have occasional people without
mess and stuff when you go to the
grocery store oh are they allowed inside
without masks
uh in some cases interesting interesting
wow
uh all right very good well i i
appreciate hearing from you
yeah you too thanks david all right
there's a dwayne from buffalo coming in
with some uh
some nice some nice praise i would say
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a massive
holiday sale on all of their products
right now
and you can take advantage of it by
going to davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality
wristwatch
really is the perfect way to add
something
fresh to your style whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else
vincero is a brand that has a serious
dedication to the craft of watchmaking
which is really evident when you look
closely at their watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black
watch and i love the sleek minimalist
design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wristwatch
from high-end materials but one that
everyday people can afford
and that's why they have over 25 000
star reviews because you won't find a
better made
watch for this great of a price anywhere
else
you can get big holiday discounts on all
of their products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video